اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم الجزيره تحصل على التفاصيل رد حماس
على مقترح اتفاق التهدئه ومصادر للجزيره
تقول ان الحركه وافقت على اتفاق للتوصل
لهدني على ثلاث مراحل نتنياهو يدعو القاده
السياسيين والعسكريين لاجتماع عاجل لبحث
رد حماس وجانتس يقول ان نتنياهو يما قتل
ويضر باهداف الحرب وبلينك يبحث مع
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين جهود الافراج عن
الاسرى كتائب القسام تقول انها هاجمت قوه
اسرائيليه تحصنت في منزل غربي خانيونس
واوقعت افرادها بين قتيل وجريح وسرايا
القدس تعلن قتل سبعه جنود كانوا يتحصنون
بمبنى غربي خان يونس والجيش الاسرائيلي
يعلن مقتل نائب قائد كتيبه في شمال غزه
وجندي اخر وقوات الاحتلال تقصف احياء
سكنيه في مختلف مناطق غزه وتوقع شهداء
وجرحى استشهاد امراه برصاص قناص اسرائيلي
واصابه شخصين لدى محاولتهم مغادره مجمع
ناصر الطبي ووزاره الصحه بغزه تقول ان 11د
الف جريح ومريض بحاجه عاجله للعلاج خارج
القطع هذا في حين حذرت الاونر من انتشار
مقلق للامراض بسبب الافتقار الصرف الصحي
والمياه النظيفه وفي الضفه الغربيه قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم بلده يعبد جنوبي جنين
ومناطق عده جنوب الخليل وتقوم بحمله دهم
وتفتيش واحتجاز لمواطنين واشتباكات بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في
قلقيليه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء